previamente hablamos con oscar camps
fundador de open arms él respondió a las
acusaciones que hizo matteo salvini el
ex ministro italiano dijo que las ong
como open arms actúan por intereses
económicos y no por humanidad
bueno nosotros somos una organización
humanitaria que nos dedicamos a proteger
la vida en el mar sobre todo en aguas
internacionales
no tenemos intercambios económicos ni si
no tenemos a ninguna ninguna otra por
radio ni civil ni militar como es el
caso de la misión italiana
él siempre nos acusa nos estaba cursando
siempre y esta es su tónica y su
estrategia no no obstante desde que está
sentado en el banquillo de los acusados
y no nosotros
camps también nos dio detalles sobre qué
pasó en 2019 cuando el entonces ministro
salvini impidió que uno de los barcos
desembarcará en la isla italiana de
lampedusa
en un principio ni siquiera nos permitía
la entrada en aguas territoriales
italianas porque
promulgó un decreto que se llama el
decreto de seguridad en el que prohibía
la entrada a aguas territoriales
italianas a cualquier barco que rescatar
a personas en aguas internacionales
tuvimos que recurrir a este decreto
ganamos ese recurso así que pudimos
entrar en aguas territoriales y una vez
allí pues tuvimos que denunciar a la
fiscalía de menores de palermo que
llevábamos unos 60 menores a bordo y que
la admistración en ghana debía hacerse
cargo no aquí empezó nuestro nuestro
programa jurídico que hemos llevado
hasta las últimas consecuencias no hasta
el desembarco hasta que el fiscal
sangriento el sobrevalor nuestra
embarcación y vino
e inspeccionar la y allí mismo dijo que
era inhumano las condiciones en las que
nos encontrábamos y que íbamos a ser
desembarcados en una hora no fue hasta
la intervención de la fiscalía que no se
nos abrió un puerto en italia esto es lo
que ocurrió con lamentablemente durante
20 días estuvimos esperando una
respuesta de la propia misión italiana o
que nos asignaron puesto un puerto
seguro el ministro de interior italiano
la cosa la cual cosa no hizo nunca y por
eso justamente está demandado disparó
este juicio no
y esto fue lo que nos dijo sobre la
inacción de la unión europea frente a la
migración
bueno lamentablemente la política de la
unión europea es una inacción deliberada
en materia de salvamento en el mar en
aguas internacionales
dejando al mar a hacer su trabajo que el
mar pues bueno se traga las las
embarcaciones la mayoría de eso para
tener a muchísimas de ellas de las
cuales no tenemos noticia ni de su
sanidad en su desaparición no obstante
en cuanto llegan a tierra pues estas
personas son puestas a la disposición de
la administración en este caso del
ministerio del interior en italia y
bueno ahí es donde son retenidas en
centros de detención en algunos casos
puertas en libertad si se les recibe
como como refugiados y en otro caso
pueden ser incluso deportados a los
países de origen
la situación es triste y lamentable y es
eso ya te digo de una
y la acción deliberada en el mar y en
tierra vulneración absoluta de los
derechos humanos